welcome back to cbs mornings all this
week we are checking in with people
we've introduced you to over the past
few years to ask one simple question
how are you now
today we're asking that question of this
man alan hawes he was a critical care
nurse on the front lines of the pandemic
who gave himself and the world powerful
perspective through pictures
over time that perspective has continued
to widen
when alan hawes goes to work at the
medical university of south carolina in
charleston he brings with him a special
ability
a talent really that he uses when he
cares for the sickest of the sick covet
patients
he takes pictures
of what you and i would usually never
see because before he became a nurse 11
years ago he spent 23 years as a
newspaper photographer
and that gives him the ability to tell
the stories of these patients this is a
gentleman named ryan simpson we had to
send him emergently to our cardiac icu
and you all believe covid is what
damaged the heart so severely oh yeah
his heart was beating so fast
for many days
135 to 165.
and this is his wife sarah so this is
the first uh moment that she saw him
that day and was i think kind of taken
aback by all the people in the room as
they were preparing to take him to the
operating room you know so many
frontline workers have said to us if
only the public could see what we see
well alan hawes convinced one of the
largest hospitals in south carolina to
allow him to give sight to what those
caregivers routinely see this is a woman
who is very sick she was with us for a
long long time and her family brought in
this prayer cloth the family wasn't able
to visit but this prayer cloth was sort
of their representative
and what happened to the lady she didn't
make it
his pictures document covid's grip as it
tightens and he was totally there as you
can see
he's texting people on his cell phone
telling them what's going on but why did
you want to capture this i felt like i
knew where he was going and what
happened
this is what happened
so two days later
i walked in and
there he was vaccinated he is
unvaccinated
so you're now at a place if i'm hearing
you right where you're like
say levy it is what it is don't want to
get vaccinated wind up here i
have quite a few times
had a patient who's unvaccinated and
i'll think to myself
you did this to yourself
but that doesn't last long
it's
part of being a good nurse is having
empathy
once you hear the stories of some of our
patients from their family members you
can become a fan of that person and you
just know that they've made a bad
decision
you humanize them
yeah you're mad at them when they come
in the door and then you start to find
out who they are i've had some really
hard times with that i mean nurses are
broken right now emotionally are you
i feel
like i am yes
every time he gets permission to
photograph either from the patients or
their family members i think people have
a message that they want to get out
there the mother holding a picture of
the newborn she can't touch
the girlfriend who keeps a bedside
journal
this is alan's colleague a nurse he's
triple vaccinated but a lifelong asthma
patient
with all due respect this is one example
where a picture
doesn't actually do it justice no it
doesn't this is a picture where i was
like man i wish i had video
ma um
well our producer was in the room with
the video camera read it i don't need
anything else
he's activated anymore
i do wonder whether some people are
going to be like
put that camera down and pay attention
just like full-time nurse yeah well when
i'm doing that they're not my patients i
don't take pictures of my own patients
finally this is mr croxton he had the
heart strings of about every nurse in
our unit i think when he was there
joel david croxton was 72 years old when
he died
this was the nurse who broke down after
she called his wife to tell her it was
time to come in and say goodbye
his wife sandy holding his hand
a nurse holding an ipad while a chaplain
prayed with him
this was the picture of croxton that
worried alan hawes
would it be too painful for his wife to
see
then again hawes usually never sees the
families again someone would like to see
you
on this day they did
alan hawes saw sandy croxton again
how are you doing this time they just
held each other
no pictures needed
just thank you
to each other
that was seven months ago
now hey david how are you i'm doing good
busier in a different kind of way not
the amount
of patients that we had before and
they're not as
generally not as sick
as they were before right after our
story about your work aired
what happened oh my goodness
uh
i mean my life changed for sure how so i
heard from people all across the country
i got handwritten
notes sent to my house thanking me for
everything that i do i heard from health
care workers across the country saying
that they felt like i was speaking for
them it was just an outstanding
experience so you've had an exhibit of
your work at a public library in town
since we saw you how did that go that
went well it was at the charleston
county public library they took just
about all my pictures from my project
and it toured around to the different
branches a lot of your pictures showed
people who were
non-believers they didn't believe kovit
was that serious or they didn't believe
in the vaccine are you still
experiencing that a lot
i am
um
although i don't
i find myself not asking as much as i
used to because a lot of times i don't
want to know the answer and he is still
capturing powerful images inside the icu
tell me about this photo you took with
the mom and daughter at the bedside of
this man
i was working in the medical icu at the
time
and one of my co-workers was telling me
how sick this gentleman was and that
they were
planning on withdrawing care from him on
that day
these were taken back in march
his name is victor rodriguez i
approached the family and asked them if
i made some photos of you in the room
with him during his last hours
and they agreed to allow that it was
gut wrenching
there was a lot of love there his wife
climbed in the bed with him to be with
him for the last time where does that
picture stand in terms of impact
on you that was a really hard one to
take i didn't want to disturb anything
and
when his wife diane got in the bed with
him i just thought that that was one of
the most beautiful things that you could
do
during the last minutes that you're
going to have
with your loved one
gut wrenching you know when he gets
permission from all these families to
take these photos yeah it's amazing the
power of that original piece is still
there you know you got the little tiny
dynamite behind the eyes you get the
little watering it's it's incredibly
emotional and the work continues i feel
like it's so impactful for him too that
he's had to overcome i don't ask as much
anymore if they're vaccinated and he
can't put himself there and i got the
sense sitting across from him jamie and
tony that he doesn't operate with a
sense of judgment he's just there to
treat and he just wants to document and
let it speak for itself yeah